Amazon founder Jeff Bezos will likely
still be the world's richest man after
his divorce from his wife Mackenzie is
finalized now under the settlement which
they announced yesterday she will
receive nearly thirty six billion
dollars in Amazon stock Forbes reports
that Bezos his wealth is estimated at
nearly one hundred and fifty billion
dollars
Tony de copal shows us how the couple's
very public's but could affect the
online retail giant Tony good morning
good morning well Amazon is 24 years old
but the bezos's have been married for 25
years and they have four children at a
time even though Mackenzie Bezos appears
to be giving up much of her share of the
couple's vast fortune she said she was
quote grateful and excited to put the
divorce behind her when all the T's are
crossed and I's are dotted on the
divorce agreement Mackenzie Bezos would
get a four percent stake in Amazon worth
more than thirty five point eight
billion dollars that would make her the
third richest woman in the world
wealthier than Nike founder Phil Knight
and Tesla CEO Elon Musk
but she's walking away with just a
quarter of the more than seventy eight
point eight million shares the couple
now owns and is also giving up all her
voting power I think it kind of showed
that Mackenzie wants to move on with her
life wired staff writer Lewis Matz Aki's
notes Mackenzie was one of Amazon's
first employees it's not just Jeff it's
not his money that she's walking away
with it's a fortune that she helped
build in a 2010 speech at Princeton
University Jeff Bezos revealed his
wife's crucial advice to him I wanted to
quit my job and go do this crazy thing
that probably wouldn't work
since most startups don't and I wasn't
sure what would happen after that
Mackenzie also Princeton grad and
sitting here in the second row told me I
should go for it
publicly the couple portrayed their
divorce as being amicable but Bezos his
infidelity was revealed by the National
Enquirer which published text messages
between him and his girlfriend former
news anchor Lauren Sanchez I think that
the divorce and the affair definitely
showed a side of Jeff Bezos that we
weren't aware of and I think it did make
some investors nervous it kind of showed
a more reckless or a more personal side
of his life which I do think was kind of
concerning to some people the divorce is
expected to final
within the next 90 days Jeff besos will
still own 12% of Amazon making him the
largest shareholder Mackenzie Bezos will
give up her claims to the Washington
Post and the space exploration company
Blu origins both of which were owned by
her husband Jeff I like they were
reporting 38.8 billion the 0.8 is worth
800 million on its own I don't know it's
I guess it's some consolation when you
come out on the short end and it but the
short end is 35 billion that's how you
go from embarrassing front page of The
National Enquirer you excited happy yes
no but wish them both well they they
both released statements about the end
of their marriage they're both very kind
and gracious to one another and I think
divorce no matter what the circumstances
I think are always very painful so the
fact that they can walk away and really
only the two of them really know all
this chatter all these people don't know
really would what goes on behind closed
doors between a couple only the two of
them know when they've decided to end it
in a very graceful stable manner and
classy manner and I think that that
matters they've got four children
together and you hope the statements
represent the reality I hope so too
I hope so too and I'm thanks to you and
the whole team that included to his
statements but at Princeton about his
wife's involvement and half Jeff's money
it's their money yeah building the
company and also being a strong she's a
smart that she's a smart cookie too all
right Tony thing